je vous propose de commencer
tranquillement puisqu'on a les les
questions
d'actualité bien mes chers collègues
nous nous recevons aujourd'hui madame
Laurence Bou qui est secrétaire d'État
chargé des affaires européennes qui va
nous rendre compte du Conseil européen
des 26 et 27 octobre dernier en amont
duquel nous avions débattu très
précocément en plainère ça fait presque
un mois déjà voilà j'espère que nous
arriverons à améliorer la situation
madame la ministre voilà on fera on va
faire des propositions et je vois
franester cet
après-midi je rappelle donc les sujets
majeurs qui étaient à l'ordre du jour du
Conseil européen l'Ukraine la révision
du cadre financier pluriannuel
l'économie et l'émigration à ces sujets
déjà difficilees c'est ajouté celui du
Proche Orient 3 semaines après l'assaut
du Hamas sur Israël c'est finalement lui
qui aura mobilisé le plus les chefs
d'État ou de gouvernement et mise à rue
d'épreuv leur unité pourriez-vous à ce
propos nous confirmer que le premier
ministre espagnol malgré sa position
théoriquement neutre de président du
Conseil app plaidé pour que l'Union
demande un cesser le feu et finalement
obtenu que les 27 appellent à
l'organisation d'une prochaine
conférence internationale sur la paix de
semaines plus tard les bellgérants
semblent sour à cet appel et
l'organisation demain en France d'une
conférence humanitaire brouille un peu
plus le message le Conseil européen
est-il finalement en mesure d'une part
de définir le rôle que devrait jouer
l'Union européenne dans le drame qui se
joue à Gaza et d'autre part de préciser
qu'il est légitime à déployer ce rôle
alors que la présidente de la Commission
européenne ne cesse de prendre des
initiatives diplomatiques au nom de
l'Union et encore une fois il y a 48 he
avec tambour et trompettes c'est un peu
un petit peu impressionnant et je le
dirais aujourd'hui un peu agaçant
d'ailleurs sur le sujet de Gaza madame
la ministre j'ai vu passer ce matin
tweet du ministère des Affaires
étrangères concernant l'arrachage de
d'affiche de de la part d'un agent du
ministère bon je vous demande pas de
rentrer dans les détails mais simplement
de nous en dire si si effectivement une
procédure a été lancée ou pas sur le
sujet parce que c'est assez inquiétant
si aujourd'hui des agents du ministère
commencent à s'exposer de cette façon
même si elle n'était plus dans le
ministère concernant la révision du
cadre financier pluriannuel les 27 n'ont
pas pu se mettre accord nombreux d'entre
eux sont réticents à l'égard de la
ralanche budgétaire que la Commission
réclame pour elle-même et deux états la
Hongrie et la Slovaquie refuse
d'accorder à l'Ukraine une nouvelle
enveloppe de 50 milliards d'euros
comment sortir de cet impasse budgétaire
d'ici le prochain Conseil européen
dernière échéance envisageable puisque
l'aide à l'Ukraine expire à la fin de
l'année de même sur la révision des
règles de gouvernance économique les
divergences persistantes rendent peu
probable un accord avant la fin de
l'année ce qui sign irit un retour dès
le 1er janvier prochain aux règles du
pacte suspendu depuis la pandémie sur le
sujet migratoire le Conseil européen n'a
pas non plus permis percer une décisive
l'Union parviendra-t-elle selon vous à
conclure le nouveau pacte asile
immigration avant l'interrupption des
trilogues dès février prochain
j'aimerais enfin vous poser deux
questions sur l'actualité des deux
semaines écoulées depuis le la réunion
du Conseil européen d'abord vous
entendre sur l'initiative qui a prise la
France d'assigner la Commission
européenne devant la Cour de justice
pour avoir recruté des fonctionnaires
sur des épreuves exclusivement en langue
anglaise notre commission qui a déjà
réclamé haut et fort un meilleur respect
du multilinguisme par la Commission
européenne se félicite de cette démarche
qui vise à faire sanctionner une telle
discrimination qui favorise les
anglophones en violation des traités
est-ce à dire que le gouvernement estime
désormais que la pression politique ne
suffit plus et que la seule voie
contentieuse peut permettre d'enrayer le
recul de l'usage du français dans les
institutions européennes enfin un mot du
paquet élargissement qu' a publié ce
matin la Commission et sur lequel se
fondera le Conseil européen de
mi-décembre pour répondre aux attentes
des Balcans
occidentaux de l'Ukraine de la Moldavie
et de la Géorgie notre ami André Richat
revient d'ailleurs de de Moldavie quelle
appréciation portez-vous sur ce rapport
de la commission et notamment sur ses
préconisations concernant la Géorgie et
la BOS Herzégovine par ailleurs
pouvez-vous nous rendre compte des
échanges que vous avez eu jeudi dernier
avec vos homologues qu'on viit à Berlin
pour discuter de la réforme interne de
l'Union qui s'impose en parallèle du
processus d'élargissement madame la
ministre c'est à vous et ensuite nous
donnerons la parole à nos collègues pour
des questions courtes avec réponses
court puisque nous avons petite heure et
demi mais nous avons le
temps merci monsieur le président
Mesdames et Messieurs les sénatrices et
les sénateurs pardon j'aurais dû couper
la phrase en deux comme vous savez c'est
d'abord un grand plaisir de retrouver
votre commission et c'est aussi un
honneur d'être ici
pour comme de coutume après chaque
Conseil européen vous vous en arrez les
principaux
sujets évidemment nous nous sommes d vu
pour quelquesuns depuis un an mais je
voulais aussi saluer les nouveaux
membres de cette commission
que je rencontre avec plaisir et et vous
dire à toutes et à tous évidemment ma
disponibilité et celle de
l'équipe lors du déjeuner vous l'avez
évoqué tout à l'heure avec les membres
du Mureau monsieur le Président vous
aviez eu la gentillesse non seulement de
me convier à ce déjeuner mais vous aviez
également assisté et vous venez de le
rappeler sur le fait qu'il était qu'il
fallait essayer autant que possible
d'avoir des auditions plus rapprochées
de la date du conseil
et donc je crois que nous pouvons nous
réjouir que pour le Conseil des 14 et 15
décembre nous ayons convenu d'une
audition le 13 décembre qui est pile
après le Conseil Affaires générales et
juste avant le Conseil
européen voilà vous avez évoqué les
questions qui étaient à l'ordre du jour
du dernier conseil qui a évidemment été
marqué par
les deux crises majeures auxquelles nous
devons faire face mais comme vous l'avez
dit une grande partie du premier
après-midi a été dédiée au conflit au
proche- Orient et puis bien sûr il y a
eu la guerre en Ukraine d'autres
dossiers internationaux du ont concerné
le Conseil européen la Serbie et le
Kosovo et nous l'occasion d'y revenir
pour l'élargissement la guerre entre
l'Arménie et l'Azerbaïdjan et le Sahel
il y a eu des échanges sur les migration
le Conseil s'est quand même mis d'accord
sur le pacte asile et migration ce qui
est positif il est effectivement entre
les mains du Parlement européen les
questions économiques sous un angle
compétitivité donc la réponse à
l'inflation reduction Act la politique
industrielle et l'énergie il y a une
évaluation de la Commission de
l'inflation reduction Act et de la
réponse dont nous pourrons parler tout à
l'heure et puis une discussion également
sur la politique budgétaire donc à la
fois le cadre financier pluriannuel et
la révision des règles de gouvernance
économique et à cet égard puisque vous
le mentionnez comme vous savez cette
semaine ont lieu un Eurogroup et un
écophine desquels nous espérons que les
choses vont avancer les chefs d'État ou
de gouvernement ayant engagé leur
ministres à conclure avant la fin de
l'année pour ne pas retomber dans les
règles anciennes qui ne font plus
beaucoup de
sens alors un peu plus en détail sur la
la situation au Proche Orient et vous
l'avez évoqué la priorité était bien
évidemment d'afficher une convergence
européenne sur ce dossier et je crois
que nous pouvons nous féliciter d'y être
parvenu puisque le Conseil a condamné
sans équivoque les attaques terroristes
du Hamas contre Israël exiger la
libération des
otages
demander le respect par tous du droit
international
humanitaire dans lequel Israël a le
droit de se défendre appelé à des pauses
humanitaires et à l'ouverture urgente
d'un accès humanitaire complet sûr et
sans entrave pour les civils de
Gaza nous allons maintenir notre aide et
notre lien avec l'Autorité palestinienne
et continons devrait pour restaurer un
horizon politique et préserver la
solution à deux états et vous l'avez
mentionné demain le président de la
République à l'initiative du Président
de la République qui est dans le cadre
du Forum pour la paix la France
accueille une conférence internationale
humanitaire qui est l'occasion de se
concentré sur l'aide humanitaire pour
les civils de
Gaza en ce qui concerne Ukraine
et encore plus j'allais dire dans le
contexte que l'on connaît puisque
l'Ukraine a évidemment peur que les
événements Proche Orient occulte ce qui
se passe à l'est de notre
continent le Conseil a rappelé que nous
soutiendrions l'Ukraine aussi longtemps
que nécessaire en démentantant l'effet
de fatigue sur lequel la Russie mise et
donc le Conseil a renouvelé son appel à
renforcer l'aide dans toutes les
dimensions économiques politique
militaire humanitaire et en matière de
sécurité
alimentaire d'ailleurs le ministre PHENO
se rendra dans une semaine au sommet qui
concerne le grain en
Ukraine en lien avec le G7 la Commission
et les États-membres sont en train de
préparer un 12e paquet de sanction qui
sera discuté euh au Conseil des affaires
étrangères lundi prochain il vise à
lutter évidemment beaucoup plus
efficacement contre le contournement des
sanctions en particulier pour les biens
à haut risque à réduire les recettes que
la Russie tire des exportations de
diamants notamment euh et puis et c'est
une des nom des questions que nous avons
euh plusieurs fois évoqué ici le Conseil
a avancer et veut continuer d'avancer
sur l'utilisation des profits tirés des
avoirs gelés et immobilisés russes pour
les mettre à la disposition de l'Ukraine
et dans un cadre juridique sûr
ensuite sur les autres sujets il y a
évidemment la situation en Arménie en
Serbie au Kosovo et au Sahel sur
l'Arménie le Conseil continue de
soutenir les efforts visants à
promouvoir la paix entre l'Arménie et
l'Azerbaïjan et explore les pistes d'
renforcement des relations entre l'Union
et
l'Arménie nous plaidons toujours pour la
reconnaissance des fondamentaux du droit
international donc reconnaissance de la
souveraineté inviolabilité des
frontières pardon et de l'intégrité
territoriale et garantir les droits à la
sécurité des Arméniens dukarabach pour
être franche avec vous la France est
vraiment le pays leader sur ce sujet et
en essayant et en arrivant je crois à
secouer un petit peu tout le
monde et et notamment en travaillant
s'il le faut à des sanctions
pour contre en tous les cas nous faisons
un appel pour y travailler contre
l'Azerbaïjan je rappelle aussi ici que
la France n'importe pas de gaz
d'azerbaïjan s'agissant de la Serbie et
du
Kosovo il y a effectivement le conseil
se heurte il y avait une réunion
préalable au Conseil européen comme vous
le savez à l'absence d'efforts par les
deux parties pour réduire les tenstion
ça va évidemment avoir des conséquences
et notamment dans le cadre de
l'élargissement puisque le Conseil
européen a rappelé que la normalisation
des relations et la
priorité et pour mémoire ça passe par la
création d'association des municipalités
à majorité serbe au Kosovo la
reconnaissance de facto par la Serbie du
Kosovo et l'organisation de nouvelles
élections dans le nord du Kosovo avec la
participation des Serbes et le retour
dans les institutions kosovares et puis
il a eu un moment sur le Sahel avec où
le Conseil européen est revenu sur la
nécessité de revoir l'approche que nous
avons en Afrique de l'Ouest et notamment
dans cette région le Haut représentant
devrait proposer des axes d'action
concret en accord avec la
commission par exemple le renforcement
de la coopération avec les états
partenaires dans la lutte contre le
terrorisme ce sont la Mauritanie le
Tchad les États du Golfe de Guinée et
bien évidemment la lutte contre
l'influence russe dans la
région voilà pour la situation
internationale les échanges ont
également porté sur la question des
migrations avec toujours les mêmes
principes he des partenariats
stratégiques globaux mutuellement
bénéfique un dialogue équilibré et
exigeant à l'égard des pays partenaires
des contreparties claires des objectifs
précis
mesurables et dans ce cadre le Conseil
européen a appelé à rapidement mettre en
œuvre le partenariat qui est conclu avec
la Tunisie et a commencé à élargir cette
méthode à d'autres pays-tiers d'origine
et de transit ainsi la Commission
travaille à l'élaboration d'un
partenariat global avec l'Égypte qui est
d'autant plus nécessaire dans le
contexte actuel euh je crois plus
largement on peut dire qu'il y a un vrai
consensus sur la nécessité de lutter
contre les entrées irrégulières et de
renforcer la politique des retours et de
le faire ensemble
euh
et ces objectifs ont nécessité que nous
révisions en parallèle notre cadre
législatif en matière d'asile et de
gestion des migration d'où l'importance
des trilogues que vous soullignez
monsieur le Président et dont l'objectif
est évidemment d'arriver à une
conclusion d'ici à la fin de la
mandature et je voudrais le rappeler ce
pacte concerne la sécurité des
frontières extérieures c'est ce dont
s'occupe l'Union européenne qui ne
s'occupe que de ça et des visas de
touristes de moins de 90 jours tout le
reste relève de la politique nationale
ce que vous savez au premier chef vu les
discussions que vous avez eu hier dans
cette
hémicycle sur les sujets
économiques et industriels donc le
Conseil a passé en revue un bon nombre
de sujets économiques et notamment
d'abord énergie et nous pouvons je crois
nous fa féliciter de l'accord du Conseil
énergie qui va nous sur la réforme du
marché européen de l'É électricité
puisqu'il va assurer à la fois la
transition les investissements pour la
transition des prix prévisibles stables
et compétitifs et c'était bien
l'objectif et c'est le premier pilier de
notre
compétitivité
ensuite le Conseil rappelé la nécessité
de progresser vers l'adoption des textes
sur l'industrie zéro émission et sur les
matières premières critiques évidemment
dans un contexte géopolitique est tendu
il est absolument crucial que nous
arrivons à conclure aussi ce texte avant
la fin de l'année
euh je vous parlais de la réponse
européenne à l'IRA euh et de la
réduction des charges qui pèsent sur
notre entreprise je dois dire que le
Conseil a euh aussi évoqué ces sujets et
notamment l'évaluation de la commission
que nous avons trouvé un peu en dessous
de nos attentes pour être diplomate
voilà mais donc nous allons faire
pression pour avoir quelque chose de
mieux puisque notre notre intérêt
évidemment soutenir de matière durable
la compétitivité de nos économies
enfin et puisque c'est la semaine où
sont est disc sont discutés les sujets
budgétaires sur le cadre financier
pluriannuel il y a eu un consensus très
clair au conseil sur la poursuite du
soutien à l'Ukraine euh pour les autres
priorités euh nous cherchons en priorité
des redéploiements nous avons trouvé que
l'enveloppe totale de que demandait la
commission était trop élevé il y avait
un consensus là-dessus et donc il ve
devit la revoir à la baisse et je tiens
à le dire ici notamment en ce qui
concerne les frais administratifs y
compris ce que l'on appellera
publiquement la masse salariale du
Conseil du de la Commission européenne
je crois que votre commission a
auditionné deux représentants de la
direction du budget et
je vous avez dû sûrement évoquer ces
enjeux et probablement j'espère ne pas
trop m'avancer sur la position la
convergence de nos vues sur ce
sujet pour la révision des les règles de
gouvernance économique comme vous savez
la France est vraiment très engagée
notamment dans la discussion avec
l'Allemagne vers la recherche d'un
compromis et le Conseil européen lui a
rappelé qu'il fallait absolument avoir
conclu le travail législatif en la
matière en 2023 il est pas possible que
nous retombions dans des règles qui
datent d'avant le covid d'avant la
guerre en Ukraine d'avant la transition
énergétique
accéléré et enfin il y a eu un petit
point sur la préparation sur les
préparatives de la COP
28 où l'Union européenne a confirmé
qu'il sera le premier continent à
atteindre la neutralité climatique d'ici
2050 les objectifs que nous avons de
réduction des émissions d'ici
2030 et je crois qu'on peut dire qu'on
est un des acteurs les plus ambitieux de
toute la COP comme je ne veux pas être
trop longue je suis sûr que nous aurons
l'occasion de revenir en détail sur
beaucoup de ces points et je vous
remercie un petit mot madame la ministre
aussi sur la la question du tweet de de
du
ministère ce sujet Rais deux choses que
j'aurais dû
euh que que j'aurais dû sur lequel
j'aurais dû vous répondre sur cette
question d'affichage le ministère des de
l'Europe et des affaires européennes a
lancé dès hier après-midi une procédure
d'enquête sur l'agent avec les possibles
responsabilités que vous imaginz par la
suite donc il y a un communiqué de
presse qui est sorti vers 5h je crois
euh hier après-midi très ferme euh et
vous m'avez interrogé aussi sur les les
concours et la langue française alors
nous avions déjà prévenu et parlé avec
plusieurs commissaires au printemps de
l'année dernière et fait une lettre euh
pour demander à ce que le français soit
rétabli comme c'est dans le cadre des
traités pour les pour les concours et
devant l'absence de résultats puisque
c'était l'objectif de votre question et
nous avons effectivement poursivi la
procédure une première audience va se
dérouler au tribunal le 23 novembre
prochain dans le cadre d'un recours en
annulation de la France à l'égard d'un
vite concours EPSO qui visait à recruter
des administrateurs dans les domaines de
l'industrie de la défense et de l'espace
c'est pas comme si nous n'avions pas
d'experts et de professionnels en ce
domaine et comme comme je vous le disais
effectivement ce recours en annulation
il répond à l'ambition de la France qui
est de promouvoir le multilinguist le
plurilinguisme au sein des institutions
européennes il n'est pas possible que
nous laissions s'installer dans le avec
le recrutement des fonctionnaires de
manière irréversible et je crois qu'
serait dommageable pour l'appartenance
et le sentiment d'appartenance à l'Union
européenne un fonctionnement totalement
décorréé des réalités linguistiques de
l'Union
européenne merci merci pour cette
fermeté he sur la langue France sur la
langue française n nous ici adoptons la
même la même fermeté en tout cas mais je
suis très surpris madame la ministre qu'
qu'on doiv en arriver c'était un peu
l'objet de ma question c'était de dire
bah finalement la voie diplomatique est
à l'interne même de la commission ou du
conseil ou même je dirais du Parlement
aussi on n'est pas capable de de de
faire imposer ce qui ce qui est ce qui
est dit dans les traités quoi c'est
c'est quand même incroyable d'en arriver
à à la question la question juridique
enfin traitée par les tribunaux ben je
trouve que c'est dommage en même temps
maintenant que passons devant les
tribunaux la pression diplomatique
redeviendra d'autant plus crédible
puisque il ne s'agit pas que de mots
nous sommes en train de montrer que nous
pouvons agir s'il le faut et je crois
qu'il fallait faire cet effort pour que
ça ne se reproduise plus ensuite oui
j'en déduis aussi peut-être que un
moment nos fonctionnaires français au
sein même de la commission sont plus
sont plus français ou ils sont ils sont
ils deviennent complètement européens
européanisés et et de la
angliciser je crois que si vous posiez
la la question
eu aux différents fonctionnaires de
l'institution européenne ils peuvent
toujours reconnaître les
Français merci nous passons chers
collègues aux questions alors j'avais
avant même de commencer la Commission
demande de prise de parole de de Jacques
ferernck merci monsieur le Président
Madame la Ministre ma madame la ministre
ma question porte sur la capacité ou non
de l'Union européenne à être à la
hauteur face à la guerre effroyable
qu'on provoquer les crimes terroristes
d'ampleur abominable du
Hamas l'Union européenne on le constate
et avec elle les pays occidentaux
globalement sont de plus en plus
incompris voire déconsidéré dans une
partie de ce qu'on peut appeler le sud
global partout on a le reproche d'un
deux poids de mesures entre notre
condamnation nette de la violation du
droit international par la Russie et
notre attitude telle qu'elle est perçu à
l'égard des violations de ce même droit
dont sont victimes des milliers de
civils et des milliers d'enfants à Gaza
alors certes le haut représentant de
l'Union a trèstôt tenu une position
équilibrée rappelant l'obligation pour
Israël de respecter le droit humanitaire
mais quelle visibilité qu'elle portait à
eu cette ligne par rapport au au signal
désastreux donné par le commissaire
varelli dans un premier temps ou
l'attitude d'Ursula vanon derlen lors de
son déplacement à Israël donnant
manifestement comme une carte blanche à
netaniao je crois qu'il y a des soutiens
inconditionnels qui soutiennent Israël
comme l'Accord de soutien le pendu et
ces vrais amis ne peuvent pas
l'encourager à reproduire les erreurs
dramatiques des USA qui avaient suivi le
11 septembre au Conseil européen la
difficulté quand même manifeste à
trouver des termes communs une
convergence avez-vous dit ça a pas
vraiment contribué encore à redresser la
ligne madame la ministre l'Europe peut
agir pour le droit humanitaire et
au-delà c'est le plus important pour
contribuer à dégager un horizon
politique pour les droits des
palestinien et la paix et la sécurité
autant pour eux pour les Israéliens
comment consolider les capacités de
l'Union à jouer pleinement en ce sens et
à être comprise comme telle au-delà du
périmètre
occidental merci Jacques audreé lineneld
puis se prépare Brigit DEA et on fera
par trois merci monsieur le Président
Audrey lincanel donc sénatrice du Nord
et nouvell membre de cette commission
donc merci pour vos mots d'accueil tout
à l'heure et plaisir partagé de pouvoir
échanger régulièrement avec vous ma
question est un peu dans le prolongement
de la précédente d'abord pour dire
que moi non plus je ne suis pas aussi
optimiste que vous sur la position de
l'Union européenne dans dans le conflit
du du Proche Orient une position
convergente ça n'est pas une une
position commune ça s'est vu y compris
aux Nations-Unies quand il s'est agi de
de voter la résolution du du 27 octobre
et je ne peux pas m'empêcher de citer
euh Joseph Borel notre haut représentant
européen pour la politique étrangère qui
lui-même reconnaissait que pour avoir
une politique étrangère commune il faut
avoir une vision du monde euh commune
euh or euh il le dit lui-même nous ne
l'avons pas le Moyen-Orient est
l'exemple de nos divisions
euh l'un des enjeux que que nous portons
euh je crois collectivement ici en
France c'est euh à la fois de tenir nos
positions euh euh dans ce conflit euh au
moyen au Proche Orient mais aussi
d'éviter qu'il ne
s'importe en France et en Europe on a
malheureusement eu à connaître à haras
dans ma région de France le drame
épouvantable que que vous connaissez
avec l'assassinat de de nom Bernard on a
eu aussi d'autres événements je pense à
Bruxelles par exemple qui montre que ça
n'est pas si facile et et ma question
est finalement un peu en rebond de de
des propos qui ont pu être tenus au
conseil sur ces attentas là dont j'ai vu
qu'ils avaient été condamnés et que le
le le Conseil apporté son soutien
évidemment au pays touchés c'est même si
sans doute vous ne l'avez pas abordé
comme ça puisque nous n'étions que les
26 et 27 octobre qu'est-ce que vous
pensez de la manière dont dont l'Europe
regarde les la recrudescence des actes
antisémites dans notre pays en Allemagne
un peu partout qui eux aussi finalement
sont une forme d'importation de ce
conflit au Proche Orient merci et pardon
d'avance pour cette question que je sais
difficile mais qui me semble important
de poser Brigitte
DEA madame la
présidente madame la Présidente pardon
madame la ministre je vais un petit peu
dans le dans la continuité de ce que
vient dire ma collègue donc suite aux
attaques du 7 octobre évidemment en
Israël et à l'exportation du conflit
dans nos démocraties il était pourant de
savoir si la régulation des plateformes
par le digital service Act atteint un
niveau de performance et d'efficacité
suffisant on sait que les moyens
financiers humains sont-ils suffisants
dans la lutte contre l'apologie du
terrorisme et surtout la censure des
propos aux sur les plateformes et les
réseaux sociaux l'arsenal juridique
question doit-il être renforcé et sur
ces derniers 30 jours 7 octobre 7
novembre quel bilan madame la ministre
pour la protection de nos démocraties et
des valeurs européennes dans cette
guerre de la communication je vous
remercie merci beaucoup pour ces
questions merci aussi de m'avoir promu
le ministre et puis la Présidente je
suis infiniment reconnaissante de ce bel
avenir que vous tracez
eu
eu plus sérieusement euh euh je vais
vous répondre Monsieur ferernck et
Madame linken dans la même réponse parce
que en fait elle se regroupe vraiment si
cel vous
va il y a une
parfaite alors on peut l'appeler
convergence de vue ou un parfait accord
en tous les cas sur les trois piliers je
crois qu'il y a vraiment trois piliers
sur lequels tous les Européens
s'entendent et ces trois piliers comme
vous le savez sont la sécurité et la
lutte contre le
terrorisme et donc ça c'est également le
droit d'Israël à se défendre dans le
respect du droit humanitaire intern
nationale le deuxème pilier c'est la
protection des populations civiles et la
question de l'aide humanitaire et donc
le le mot que nous avons prononcé
vraiment c'est nous voulons une trêve
humanitaire et qui à terme pour amener à
C le feu mais en tous les cas trêve
humanitaire et avec le le conseil et
d'accord et sur les le troisième pilier
qui est la reprise d'un processus
politique et ça je pense que c'est
vraiment le cœur de ce qu'ils ont dit
euh effectivement aux Nations Unies euh
vous avez vu que les votes n'étaient pas
tous les mêmes euh on peut l'expliquer
parce que une absence de mots compte
parfois autant qu'une présence de mots
et là il manquait des mots pour certains
profondément ça reflète aussi l'histoire
et d'où l'on vient si vous regardez les
groupes de votes ce qui s'est passé
pendant la Seconde Guerre mondiale et
après explique en grande partie ce
différentiel des votes mais l'Ance et je
crois que nous continuions euh deux
choses d'abord à à en parler au conseil
et entre les conseils et au G7 pour
avoir cet accord sur les fondamentaux
qui sont ceux que je viens de d'écrire
mais vous soulevez il me semble à moyen
terme la question de la réforme de
l'Union européenne et de ce qu'on peut
faire effectivement en matière
d'affaires étrangères
puisque'aujourd'hui on a un Conseil
Affaires étrangères qui sert à se
coordonner on a une boussole stratégique
et nous n'avons pas encore
opérationnalisé cette boussole
stratégique euh quand nous élargirons
les l'Union européenne en parallèle il y
aura la réforme de l'Union européenne et
de ses politiques et je pense que
l'opérationnalisation de la boussole
stratégique et de ce que nous voulons
faire ensemble et pas que coordonner en
matière d'affaires étrangères et un
point important de la prochaine m nature
euh de l'Union euh de la Commission et
du Parlement et j'en profite pour vous
dire que si vous avez des suggestions
question et des choses que vous voulez
qu'on porte je suis à votre disposition
pour en pour en
discuter deux petits autres points pour
répondre à ces questions je rappelle
qu'Ursula van derlayen a parlé en son
nom propre elle n'a pas de fonction en
la matière et ça a été parfaitement
rappelé par tout le monde quant au
commissaire varelli effectivement il y a
une correction ensite il y a deux choses
un nous avons augmenté l'aide
humanitaire en direction des civiles de
Gaza au niveau européen comme au niveau
français et de nous nous assurons et il
y a un processus de vérification assez
complexe pour s'assurer que l'aide
humanitaire arrive là où elle doit
arriver en matière
d'antisémitisme il y a une stratégie
deunion européenne qui date de
2021 il y a eu d'ailleurs un communiqué
que vous avez vu ce weekend de la part
de la Commission mais qui ne mentionne
pas cette stratégie euh de lutte contre
l'antisémitisme nous sommes en train de
mettre la pression d'abord diplomatique
sur la commission pour savoir où nous en
sommes puisque un des points de cette
stratégie et de recenser pour chaque
pays les actes antisémites et à ce stade
et au meilleur de ma connaissance à ce
stade puisque nous sommes dessus 13 pays
ne le font pas or il faut commencer par
nommer et recenser un mal pour en
connaître l'ampleur et ensuite s'y
attaquer donc vous pouvez compter sur
nous pour suivre et je suis à nouveau à
votre disposition pour en
reparler voilà madame la sénatrice et
merci de votre mot d'ailleurs au début
madame la sénatrice des AL vous vous
posez une question compliquée à laquelle
je vais
répondre de façon assez factuel je pense
que nous avons depuis la présidence
française de l'Union européenne et avec
le DSA DMA un arsenal qui est assez
complet pour s'attaquer
effectivement au discours de haine en
ligne et sur les réseaux sociaux et les
incitations à des actes terribles avant
de parler de renforcer l'arsenal nous
sommes en fait dans la phase de mise en
œuvre de ce qui existe et je vais vous
citer un exemple chaque pays doit nommer
un
coordinateur pour recenser et pour
s'attaquer aux plateformes or tous les
pays n'ont pas encore nommé leur
coordinateur nous avons je crois 2 mois
sous le contrôle de mes voisins de mois
pour faire cela et donc je pense qu'on
pourra voir s'il faut renforcer c'est à
à l'issue de ces de mois et dans
l'intervalle évidemment la Commission et
le commissaire Thierry Breton de même
que nous sommes extrêmement vigilants et
parlons aux plateformes pour ne pas
faire de ces 2 mois un vacum je vous
remercie alors Cyril pelva et se prépare
Florence
blatrix madame la ministre lors du
Conseil européen il a évoqué la volonté
de parvenir à une autonomie stratégique
tout en préservant une économie ouverte
et respectueuse des principes de libre
concurrence le Conseil européen a
insisté sur la nécessité d'accélérer les
travaux tels que la réduction aux
principales dépenses critiques
dépendances critique et la
diversification des chaînes
d'approvisionnement au moyens de
partenaires stratégiques les
partenariats avec des pays-tiers pour la
fourniture de ressources stratégiques
présentent en effet un double enjeux
diplomatique et économique diplomatique
dans un premier temps car la dépendance
de l'UE à un pays tiers peut affaiblir
sa politique étrangère économique
d'autre part car les différents
politiques avec nos partenaires ont des
répercussions directes sur l'économie
européenne comme nous l'avons vu lors de
l'invasion de l'Ukraine par la Russie
bien que la rupture des relations
commerciales concerne le gaz ait été
effectuée cette décision fut beaucoup
plus difficile à prendre pour les pays
européens fortement dépendant du gaz
russe les conséquences économiques de
l'embargo sur le gaz russe jusqu'ici la
principale source d'approvisionnement de
l'UE ont été massiv pour palier la
rupture des relations énergétiques avec
la Russie lieu s'est tourné vers
d'autres partenaires comme l'Azerbaïjan
pour se fournir en gaz encore une fois
les relations énergétiques et nos
dépendance enversazerbaïjan ont
fortement limité la réponse diplomatique
de l'Union lors de l'offensive de
l'Azerbaïjan contre l'Arménie en
septembre dernier il apparaît donc
nécessaire que soit mis en place des
mesures de sélection de nos partenaires
stratégiques afin d'éviter toute
aliénation et contrecoup économique dû à
un partenariat mal choisi aussi je
souhaiterais savoir si Conseil européen
envisage des mesures qui pourraient être
mis en place lors du processus de
sélection de partenaires économiques
étranger afin de s'assurer de leur
fiabilité
merci Florence et André richichard se
préparent merci monsieur le Président
Madame la Ministre j'aurais deux
questions la première qui n'est pas
strictement en lien avec le Conseil
européen mais qui est qui est quand même
un lien indirect parce que il s'agit de
souveraineté économique et même plus
précisément de notre souveraineté
numérique AWS a annoncé une nouvelle
offre de cloud souverain dédié à ses
clients européens
elle promet une séparation physique de
ces autres régions la BSI allemande a
adoubé cette offre et il existe une
crainte que les Allemands exercent une
pression contre la France
dirigé contre la certification française
qui est la plus aboutie au niveau
européen c'est notre certification sec
cloud on avait déjà eu des divergences
et en fait je crois que c'est des
divergences de fond avec l'Allemagne sur
ce qu'est un Cloud souverain en réalité
et ça avait quand même pénalisé le
projet GAA x parce que je crois qu'on
avait pas la
même la même vision de ce qu'est un
Cloud souverain donc face à cette
annonce récente de ce par Amazon Web
Service de son Cloud européen qui
suscite toujours des inquiétudes quant à
l'extraterritorialité avec les lois
américaines FISA et Cloud Act comment le
gouvernement prévoit-il de réagir à la
position unilatérale de l'Allemagne qui
cherche à prendre initiative dans ce
domaine et donc comment est-ce que vous
envisager de de préserver la
souveraineté numérique française et
notamment la certification sec
cloud euh ma seconde question portait
sur euh le cadre financier pluriannuel
donc les les 27 ont réaffirmé leur
opposition finalement à la rallonge de
66 milliards et euh nous pouvons
craindre dès lors euh nous avons entendu
les déclarations de la directrice
générale du budget au sujet de potentiel
redéploiement qui pourrait euh conduire
à des réductions budgétaires drastiques
pourront euh pouvant attendre atteindre
30 % dans des des domaines cruciau
cruciaux tels qu'Horizon Europe Erasmus
Erasmus et digital Europe donc quelle
est la position du Gouvernement sur ces
éventuels redéploiements qui pourrai
vraiment pénaliser des des politiques
européennes importantes je vous remercie
André
oui merci monsieur le Président Madame
la Ministre d'abord une observation à
mon tour je voudrais féliciter pour
l'action contentieuse engagée par la
France
concernant le plurilinguisme
indispensable ou l'absence de
plurilinguisme qui pourtant est
indispensable dans cette union
européenne moi je voudrais juste vous
indiquer que comme ça a été dit tout à
l'heure pour avoir fait un déplacement
en Moldavie
réunion d'une journée organisée par par
le gouvernement
moldave afin de présenter aux
différentses délégations des parlements
européens les progrès qui ont été
réalisés par ce pays depuis l'accession
au statut de de de de
candidat à l'entrée à l'Union
Européenne j'ai été vraiment
estomaqué très clairement par le fait
que la seule langue qui était la langue
de travail utilisée pour pour cette
rencontre c'était l'anglais bien et et
tout le monde sans sans tout le monde a
accepté cela quoi tout le monde a
accepté cela je répète on est quand même
euh dans un pays qui euh souhaite
accéder à l'Union européenne c'est
vraiment pour moi un mauvais signe donné
à la fois par le pays euh mais aussi par
par les délégations qui n'ont rien dit
quoi qui n'ont rien dit à cet égard les
seuls qui euh qui qui qui qui ont
contrevenu à la règle ce sont les
Italiens euh ils ont parlé
italien et ils sont venus simplement
avec deux interprètes italiens eux-mêmes
voilà qui ont fait l'effort de de
interprétariat pour moi ça excusez-moi
d'être aussi direct c'est ça tient pas
la route quoi ça tient vraiment pas la
route moi j'aurais été
candidat je faisais l'effort quoi bien
d'autant plus que l'Union européenne
vous le savez bien d'ors et déjà met un
peu d'argent sur la table quand même
hein pour pour pour pour aider ces gens
donc ça c'était juste une
observation des des des questions merci
d'abord madame la ministre pour pour ce
compte-rendu euh ça va pas vous étonner
première question va porter vraiment sur
le pacte asile migration vous avez été
assez comment je vais dire assez Brè
voilà assez Brè sur ce compte-rendu
euh voilà les résultats pour pour vous
sont plutôt conformes moi avant
avant ce ce conseil lorsqu'on avait eu
l'occasion de de de de vous
interroger dans en
séance je vous avais laissé entendre ma
enfin je vous avais interrogé sur je
crois me souvenir des termes utiliser
est-ce que vous croyez vraiment voilà
que on va pouvoir aboutir à un consensus
donc vous avez été un peu bref sur ça
moi j'aimerais savoir vraiment où quels
sont les résultats véritables est-ce
qu'il y a à votre avis véritablement un
consensus ou est-ce que c'est un
consensus de façade pour 36000 raisons
que vous pouvez connaître comme moi
venant notamment des pays entre
guillemets de de de seconde ligne enfin
de de relocalisation éventuelle ou
potentielle voilà est-ce qu'il y a
vraiment un accord est-ce que ça va
vraiment avancer est-ce que c'est pas
juste pour préparer les
élections européennes prochaine qu'on
s'efforce de mettre en place quelque
chose vous avez compris c'est très
important parce que comme vous le disiez
euh l'Union Européenne a une compétence
très forte sur la maîtrise de ses
frontières extérieures voilà et nous mes
chers collègues on peut s'poumonner
s'poumonner S7 ans sur un discours
franco-français ces jours-ci si à
l'extérieur il y a pas des frontières
qui sont aussi étanches que possible et
qu'on on on laisse rentrer ce qui
méritent véritablement le le le statut
de de de pays demandeur d'asile euh vont
continuer à rentrer comme ça c'est donc
voilà o où est-ce qu'on en est vraiment
voilà sur ça c'était ma première
question est-ce que vous pouvez
aussi vous exprimer un peu sur le Sahel
en d'utre vous disiez que des actions
concrètes étaient à l'étude est-ce qu'on
peut en dire un peu plus parce que là
aussi le fait on en parle plus de Sael
moi m'inquiète beaucoup parce que
l'entreprise
euh de démolition de l'Afrique de
l'Ouest je le dis en qualité de
président du groupe d'amitié France
Afrique de l'Ouest l'entreprise de
démolition continue euh vous savez c'est
comme pendant les travaux pendant les
travaux la vente continue voilà bah
là-bas ça continue et et tous les signes
que nous recevons à longueur de temps
montre que c'est pas parce qu'on a
quitté le Mali respectivement maintenant
le Niger que pour autant ça s'arrange
pas du tout voilà est-ce que l'Union
européenne se sent vraiment concerné ou
non enfin c'est quand même important ça
voilà 3è et j'en aurais presque terminé
vous avez parlé du conflit Arménie
Azerbaïdjan ce sont deux pays qui qui
qui sont en partenariat
oriental avec l'Union européenne en
partenariat oriental avec l'Harmonie
quelque chose a été conclu avec l'azer
gens non bien mais quand même euh le
Partenariat oriental c'est c'est un sas
enfin c'est comme ça qu'on le voit on le
voit bien avec
avec d'autres pays le Partenariat
oriental a servi de préparation
clairement a servi de préparation pour
une entrée pour déposer un dossier de
candidat à l'entrée de l'Union
européenne bon et on met de l'argent sur
la table dans le Partenariat oriental
est-ce que cette union européenne
euh ne peut pas utiliser un effet un
effet à cet égard un effet il a
excusez-moi à part les
gesticulations de de haute personnalité
et par charité chrétienne je ne les
citerai pas de l'Union européenne à part
ça on VO pas grand-chose bien donc
est-ce que il y a pas lieu là et est-ce
que vous en est-ce qu'on en a parlé de
dire mais attendez ça va pas du tout
notamment avec l'Azerbaïjan est-ce
est-ce que clairement alors je sais bien
que ils nous en veulent particulièrement
maintenant mais mais est-ce qu'on peut
pas utiliser le le le le levier
Partenariat oriental avec ces deux pays
pour essayer
d'obtenir des avancées concrètes et
enfin et c'est vraiment complètement
terminé je sors du Conseil puisque le
président tout à l'heure vous a aussi
interrogé là-dessus en matière
d'élargissement ce jour voilà ce jour la
commission
euh prend un rapport sur la suite à
donner en la matière
euh est-ce que est-ce que vous êtes
informé de de ce qui ENF encore que bien
sûr on a des échos est-ce que vous êtes
informé plus précisément euh de de de
l'avancée euh euh des avancées donné à
la fois aux candidats qui ont été
retenus à cet égard et du sort derrière
de la Géorgie qui est resté devant la
porte mais qui n'en pense pas Mo je vous
remercie je vais juste donner la parole
à Claude Kerne puisque sa question elle
est dans le même sens sur sur la
question de l'élargissement et de du
rapport de la commission
oui donc je vais aller madame la
ministre dans le même sens qu'André
reichchart sur l'élargissement puisque
j'ai moi j'ai eu le le rapport que la
Commission a présenté ce matin qui
concerne notamment l'élargissement
envers la geéorgie pour la geéorgie la
candidature de la geéorgie donc que là
aussi le rapport est en anglais André je
su désolé
mais la Géorgie comme on le découvre à
travers ce rapport essae d'être en
conformité avec de se mettre en
conformité avec les 12 priorités qui lui
avaient été fixé en juin 2022 de
nombreux progrès sont notés et plus de
la moitié des 12 priorités
aujourd'hui sont enfin la geéorgie est
en conformité notamment avec la réforme
de l'administration publique le combat
contre la corruption le combat contre le
crime organisé les droits fondamentaux
les libertés d'expression et liberté de
la presse l'égalité des genres euh la
protection de la femme et cetera il
reste néanmoins une question très
sensible qui a été vaguement évoqué dans
ce rapport mais qui je pense est
essentiel c'est la réforme globale du
système
judiciaire puisque il reste beaucoup de
failles en tant que rapporteur pour la
commission de suivi du Conseil de
l'Europe sur la Géorgie j'ai noté de
nombreuses failles dans dans ceci et
d'ailleurs la commission de Vénise après
notre rapport a émis exactement les
mêmes réserves que nous en ce qui
concerne le système judiciaire et puis
j'irai plus loin puisque euh dans le
cadre de l'élargissement il y a des
questions qui restent ouvertes notamment
la question des des Balcans avec la
poudrière que représente aujourd'hui euh
le le Kosovo enfin c'est pas le Kosovo
qui représente la poudrière mais plutôt
la Serbie alors je voulais voir comment
se positionne également la France sur
ces deux
sujets vous avez combien de
temps d'accord
euh merci beaucoup
alors euh sur l'autonomie stratégique
monsieur le sénateur et et les principes
de libre concurrence euh plusieurs
choses plusieurs choses ici la la
première comme je venais de le dire
c'est effectivement d'assurer la
compétitivité de notre de notre de nos
notre économie qui représente 440
millions de citoyens euh et pour assurer
cette compétitivité et son autonomie et
effectivement nous ne pouvons pas vivre
en autarsie comme comme vous l'avez
souligné et c'est d'ailleurs pour ça que
nous avons commencé à faire
des accords commerciaux stratégiques par
exemple si vous regardez entre l'Union
européenne et le Chili qui nous a permis
d'avoir accès à beaucoup de lithium qui
est effectivement nécessaire pour la
transition
énergétique vous avez raison que la
dépendance de chaque pays de l'Union
européenne au gaz qui soit russe ou
azerbaïjanais varie d'un pays à l'autre
en revanche je crois qu'on ne peut être
que saluer les efforts de tout le monde
pour avoir réussi à réduire la
dépendance au gaz russe dans son
ensemble de 50 % cette année il y a
effectivement un process en un processus
qui existe pour que les pays discutent
entre eux de leur dépendance pour qu'on
arrive à les identifier et à voir où
elles sont trop cumulées mais c'est
aussi si l'objet du rapport que la
présidente présidente de la commission
Ursula van derl a demandé au président à
l'ancien président du Conseil italien
Mario Draghi de regarder effectivement
comment on pouvit rendre l'Union
européenne plus compétitive quelles
étaient les dépendances critiques
comment on pouvait se détacher de ces
dépendances critiques et comment est-ce
qu'il
fallait diversifier siinep par exemple
si on regarde ce qui vient de Chine en
matière de de d'iPhone en quoi on est
dépendant de la Chine à quelle hauteur
sur quel objet précisément donc c'est
effectivement un travail en cours qui ne
sera pas lui fini je pense à l'été
puisque d'abord vous savez que le
Parlement s'arrêtera avant l'été ensuite
le rapport de je viens de vous faire
part de Mario dragi est prévu pour juin
et devra servir pour la prochaine
commission voilà j'espère que ça répond
à votre question euh sur le Cloud madame
la sénatrice alors plusieurs choses
d'abord soyez assuré que pour nous le
plus important c'est que les données
européenne soit dans un Cloud qui est
localisé en Europe et que le transfert
de données avec les États-Unis je crois
que nous avions eu l'occasion d'en
parler ici est encadré je nous en avons
même parlé il me semble c'était votre
question avant le lors du débat avant le
Conseil
européen il y a au moins deux choses
importante pour nous d'abord assurer la
compétitivité du marché européen des
données et ensuite protéger la
souveraineté de l'Union européenne et
notamment en lorsqu'il s'agit des
données des citoyens donc ce que nous
voulons nous c'est faire émerger un
service européen en la matière et à ce
stade aucune offre n'a été certifiée par
l' NC secnum cloud ce qui veut dire que
l'exigence française en la matière est
préservé et que nous allons être très
vigilant sur ce point j'en ai parlé de
nombreuses fois à JN barreau en fait je
lui en parle à chaque fois que je vais à
la commission euh et plus récemment avec
euh
euh pour le sujet que vous évoquez
chaque pays a aujourd'hui son Cloud
notre objectif à nous c'est que euh on
fasse converger cette fois je pense que
ça sera important vers la notion de
Cloud souverain français euh qui je
crois est la plus protectrice euh de
toutes celles qu'on a donc nous allons
être euh vigilants et je peux continuer
de vous rapporter au fur et à mesure des
avancées euh sur ce sujet euh je voulais
juste ajouter quelque chose là-dessus
d'abord nous discutons tout le temps
avec l'Allemagne de ce sujet le
numérique et l'intelligence artificielle
était au programme de Hambourg il a été
discuté la semaine dernière lors du
premier sommet euh britannique euh et
euh je pense que c'est l'occasion de
rappeler qu'en matière de développement
numérique et de Cloud la France se situe
en tête
des pays de l'Union européenne et donc
bien évidemment devant
l'Allemagne voilà pour
le cadre financier
pluriannuel je CIS il y a vraiment deux
principes le premier c'est que il y a
des fonds qui n'ont pas été utilisés
notamment tout ce qui est dédié à la
migration d'une
part d'autre part la hausse demandée par
la commission était pas n'était qu'un
parfaitement documenté ce qui est pas
normal et troisièmement nous pensons que
à l'heure où les fonctionnaires
nationaux sont soumis quand même à une
certaine forme
de on des Haus de salire sont un peu
restreintes vu la situation actuelle il
est difficilement acceptable pour les
pays et là les 27 sont unanimes de en
fait permettre à la commission
d'augmenter beaucoup plus c'est les
employés qui ont déjà généralement un
niveau de rémunération plus élevé que
les fonctionnaires nationaux donc ce que
nous leur demandons nous c'est et comme
l'ensemble des pays c'est de regarder ce
qui peut être utilisé qui n'a pas été
utilisé et redéployer quand c'est
nécessaire si ça peut l'être mais bien
évidemment il y a des programmes
prioritaires donc j'ai mentionné
l'Ukraine tout à l'heure la migration
est également un programme prioritaire
pour nous et rasmous fait partie des
priorités horizon fait partie des
priorités et de la même façon que le le
numérique fait partie des priorités je
crois que plus on va devoir être
sélectif plus il faudra être stratégique
et ça les trois programmes que vous avez
cité sont parmi les plus stratégiques
pour pour l'Europe notamment lorsqu'on
parle de souveraineté d'autonomie
stratégique donc on est en train nous de
regarder de faire nos propositions de
redéploiement comme d'autres pays
européens ont déjà commencé à le
faire monsieur le sénateur
je je pars partage sur la langue à
nouveau vraiment c'est quelque chose qui
nous occupe depuis depuis qu'il y a eu
une publication de post qui permettait
d'utiliser seulement deux langues ce qui
évidemment veut dire que vous parlez
votre langue maternelle et il y a de
grandes chances que ce soit l'anglais ce
qui n'était absolument pas acceptable
donc nous avons eu des discussions à la
fois informelles puis Formell puis une
lettre et puis nous allons continuer
d'escalader je crois que nous sommes
assez soutenus par l'ensemble des pays
européens vous avez mon par exemple mon
collègue irlandais s'exprime parfois en
gaelique et je trouve ça assez ironique
à l'heure où les Espagnols demandent de
faire un effort pour ce qui concerne la
langue régionale ce qui n'est pas dans
les traités pour le coup qu'on ne fasse
pas déjà le multilinguisme qui fait
partie des traités donc nous sommes
parfaitement alignés sur ce
sujet le pacte à lesmigration
asilemigration pour des raisons de fond
et pour des raisons politiques je pense
P que nous aboutirons avant la fin de
l'année et en tous les cas nous nous
allons tout faire pour aboutir avant la
fin de la mandature c'est extrêmement
important pour montrer que l'Europe est
effectivement efficace et agit pour la
protection des frontières extérieures il
y a un large consensus au Conseil tous
les pays savent bien que ça part par là
regardez madame mélonie qui pendant 6
mois nous a expliqué qu'elle fera un
blocus naval et qui finalement est venu
cherchersa VL et l'ensemble des pays
européens pour aller faire pression sur
d'autres pour aller discuter pardon et
négocier avec d'autres pays qui sont
soit des pays de transite soit des pays
d'origine donc j'allais dire quelle que
soit la couleur politique le consensus
est là que la protection des frontières
de l'Union européenne passe par l'Union
européenne s'il reste un pays qui il
restait deux pays qui faisaient un peu
de blocage dans un des pays la majorité
va changer et dans l'autre vous savez
qu'ils ont par ailleurs d'autres sujets
avec la commission sur lesquels
évidemment ils essayent de discuter mais
je crois que le signal envoyé par le
changement de stratégie de l'Italie est
quand même un signal très fort et doit
être un signal très fort à l'ensemble du
spectre politique
eu le Parlement européen lui-même a tout
intérêt à à arriver à un accord avec le
Conseil il aurait aucun sens et je pense
que 7 mois avant les échéances
européennes si le Parlement européen
n'arrivait pas à à à conclure avec le
conseil sur un accord ça serait un
signal de faiblesse assez terrible donc
pour ça c'est pour les raisons politique
et sur les raisons de fond on a fait une
véritable avancée avec ce pacte et si je
prends les choses de façon très concrète
avant le pacte les migrants arrivent par
le pays de première entrée et puisqu'on
ne connaît pas leur statut doivent se
faire enregistrer dans ces pays et
normalement leur demande traiter dans
ces pays donc bien évidemment quand on
est un pays avec des côtes
méditerranéennes qui font l'ensemble du
pays on est un premier un pays de
première entrée qui voit arriver un
nombre beaucoup plus important de
demandeurs que dans n'importe quel autre
pays de l'Union si vous avez tous à les
traités et que personne n'est solidaire
avec vous grande est la tentation de ne
pas traiter tout le monde et donc on ne
maîtrise pas complètement maintenant que
nous offrons la solidarité que vous
connaissez qui est que chacun va prendre
sur son sol la demande de traitement va
aider avec les tests sanitaires les
tests sécuritaires va on va pouvoir
aller plus vite aux frontières également
le pays les pays en question ont bien
évidemment intérêt à enregistrer les
demandes contrairement à ce qui existait
avant donc ça c'est un symbole
d'efficacité très pratique et c'est bien
pour ça queon a l'ensemble des pays qui
est d'accord pour procéder ainsi donc
sur le fond je pense qu'effectivement la
maîtrise des flux migratoires va être
énormément augmenté par ce pacte asile
et immigration et c'est pour ça que ça
serait incompréhensible qu'on narrive
pas à un accord j'espère que je vous ai
donné assez ou plus de détails sur le
sujet
h sur
euh
le l'ARM alors vous avez ensuite ce sont
plus des questions
international sur l'Arménie Azerbaïdjan
pardon j'ai j'ai du mal à relire mes
notes je vais faire l'élargissement pour
juste demander de qu'on clarifie la
question ici à côté de
moi avant l'élargissement le Sahel
effectivement donc sur notre insistance
le Conseil européen l'a mis à l'ordre du
jour c'était une demande de la France je
crois qu'on peut le dire et qui a qui
tenait évidemment l'ensemble des pays
suit et a conscience de l'importance de
cette région ne serait-ce que pour la
stabilité à la fois sur le continent et
chez nous le président dans et en
général celui qui est le plus leader sur
le sujet qui tient le langage de fermeté
qu'il faut et en résultat de cette
discussion le Haut représentant a été
mandaté pour pouvoir travailler sur une
position commune et enfin se mettre à
agir
sur le partenariat oriental c'était ça
que je n'arrivais pas à relire dans mes
notes et l'Arménie
azerbaïjan le sujet
aujourd'hui si si on regarde les choses
un peu froidement c'est que malgré les
multiples réunions entre l'Arménie et
l'Azerbaïdjan l'Azerbaïdjan a décidé de
de manquer à sa parole et et de pousser
tout 100000 personnes si mes souvenirs
sont bons puisque 25000 étaient déjà
parti hors de la région dans laquelle
ils habitaient donc c'est un manquement
c'est c'est une enfin céit un acte
d'agression sur la souveraineté et et la
protection
territoriale on peut d'ailleurs supposer
que ça a peut-être un à voir avec le
fait que les repr il n'y avait pas de
représentant d'Azerbaïdjan à la
communauté politique européenne qui a eu
lieu comme vous savez début
octobre de nombreuses discussions ont eu
lieu est-ce que la France fait et elle
prend à nouveau le leadership en la
matière c'est de demander qu'on soit
plus qu'on fasse plus de pression sur
l'Azerbaidjan au cas où il ne
s'arrêterait pas là et nous demandons de
préparer des sanctions euh et nous
demandons de préparer du soutien
militaire également et tout ça va être
discuté au Conseil des affaires
étrangères la semaine
prochaine sur
euh
l'élargissement je vais euh vous dire
quelque chose de général avant d'être
plus particulier je je pense que ce qui
est important sur l'élarchissement c'est
de se poser la question est-ce qu'on
veut que les pays des Balcans l'Ukraine
la Moldavie et la Géorgie soi avec nous
du côté des pays démocratiques avec le
respect de l'État de droit des valeurs
communes humanitaires euh sur la
protection des minorités sur vraiment
anti-corruption l'impartialité
l'indépendance de la justice
l'indépendance et la pluralité des
médias enfin tout ce qui nous rassemble
ou est-ce qu'on veut les laisser
dérivver vers la Russie et la Chine et
la réponse politique pour nous il me
semble qui de notre intérêt sécuritaire
c'est que ces pays soient avec nous et
que nous n'ayons pas à nos frontières
des pays qui risquent d'être
déstabilisés à tout moment par de
l'ingérence russe ou chinoise si on se
dit les choses donc bien évidemment il
faut travailler à
pouvoir à les aider sur le Pass sur le
processus chemin d'adhésion à l'Union
européenne et maintenant évidemment par
à n'importe quel prix l'idée c'est
qu'ils adoptent nos institutions qui
garantissent un état de droit et c'est
exactement ce que nous allons faire et
c'est pour ça que nous avons cette proc
que nous avons demandé ce processus
d'intégration graduelle qui est vous
faites des efforts et des progrès sur
l'état de droit et nous vous aidons
financièrement et administrativement à
avancer plus vite en revanche vous
régressez et ben vous allez aussi
régresser sur le chéma d'adhésion donc
il faut il faut qu'on soit suffisamment
incitatif et qu'on fasse suffisamment
rêver pour les ancrer dans les systèmes
démocratiques et c'est bien tout l'objet
de ce paquet élargi
maintenant si on regarde
avec un peu plus de précision
effectivement la résolution des conflits
doit être une condition quand on pense à
la Serbie et Kosovo et ça sera dans
l'élargissement et
franchement ils ont les moyens de
résoudre ce conflit ils les ont c'est
vraiment entre leurs mains et ils sont
aidés de toute part pour le
faire la deuxième
chose que c'est que s'il y a un recul
sur l'état de droit et ben nous en
prendrons acte et tout vous savez que
toutes les conditions pour que les pays
pour qu'on ouvre ce statut d'adhésion à
la négociation de façon plus automatique
sont lié à l'état de droit et en ce qui
concerne la Géorgie plus
particulièrement ils ont rempli trois
priorités sur
12 donc ce qu'on va faire c'est on va
leur dire que évidemment ils ont on va
leur donner le statut de candidat dès
qu'ils auront rempli les neuf autres
conditions si vous vous rappelez c'est
un peu le c'est un peu ce qu'on a fait
pour l'Albanie et la Macédoine du Nord
c'est de dire qu'on ouvrait
automatiquement dès lors que les
conditions était rempli qu'on avait pas
besoin de refaire un processus un examen
et cetera donc on lance le signal
politique et en même temps on reste très
très fort sur l'état de droit j'espère
que j'ai oublié aucune de vos questions
merci merci
oui ou oui
allez-yy
merci madame la ministre je souhaitais
comment je souhaitais rebondir sur le
sujet des négociations autour du cadre
financier
pluriannuel un certain nombre de
priorités ont été évoquées lors du
dernier Conseil européen vous en avez
donné aussi aujourd'hui quelques-unes en
terme de priorités françaises pour
l'instant on a peu entendu parler du
Green Deal ou du pacte vert en français
et sur les priorités données euh ça
s'appliquait plutôt à la gestion de la
crise climatique plutôt que de la
prévention de cette crise le président
de la République a envoyé un signal
assez négatif il y a quelques mois en
parlant de pause dans la réglementation
européenne en matière environnementale
alors quelles sont les priorités de la
France dans le cadre financier
pluriannuel en matière de lut lutte
contre le changement climatique et de la
perte de la
biodiversité
merci beaucoup alors en ce qui concerne
la lutte contre le changement climatique
je crois
que je sais que ça peut vous surprendre
mais nous avons avec l'Europe la région
la plus écologique au monde et la plus
avancée en matière de transition
écologique je vous mets au défi de
trouver une région dans le monde qui
fait autant pour le climat et pour la
biodiversité et
j'oserait être audacieuse en disant que
c'est le président de la République qui
est le plus Auda et ambitieux de tous
les leaders au Conseil européen c'est
assez factuel il suffit de ben il suffit
de regarder le conseil et ses éléments
et nous avons effectivement nous serons
probablement le premier prédit à être le
plus décarboné je vous rappelle que
l'Allemagne qui dans sa coalition a
également des verres est loin derrière
nous en matière de décarbonation et de
transition
écologique en ce qui concerne la POS RG
m l'idée était pas du tout de s'arrêter
dans la démarche de transition
énergétique et de biodiversité mais bien
plutôt de regarder tout ce qui avait été
fait d'en jauger l'impact et s'il le
faut d'ajuster dans un sens ou dans un
autre en fonction des résultats qu'on
attend de ces politiques parce que être
très ambitieux et afficher des cibles
tout le monde peut le faire c'est facile
de parler en revanche le faire c'est
beaucoup plus difficile donc la
prochaine étape moi je pense que ce sera
euh les interconnexions énergétiques
notamment pour pouvoir optimiser et la
production et la consommation d'énergie
et ça ça sera probablement dans le
mandat de la Banque européenne
d'investissement et de son ou sa
prochaine présidente euh et puis euh la
même chose sur les autres volet
écologique qui est de la mise en œuvre
de l'opérationnel et effectivement
d'ajuster les normes là où il le faudra
et comme vous savez euh le commissaire
Marco serkovic est en train de faire un
tour des capitales européennes pour dis
discuter avec à la fois les entreprises
et la société civile pour voir comment
on peut ajuster un ce qui a été fait de
façon à ce que et les entreprises et la
société civile puissent effectivement
mettre les choses en œuvre de la façon
la plus efficace et la moins coûteuse
pour elle possible
merci voilà donc 1 2 3 pas d'autres
questions merci beaucoup madame la
ministre on se revoit donc